Die lage in syrien ist hochexplosiv doch für die rund eine halbe million opfer inzwischen
interessiert sich mittlerweile kaum noch jemand denn wir hier sind ja nicht direkt beteiligt vor einem möglichen dritten weltkrieg dagegen der uns alle treffen würde
Fürchtet sich die ganze welt doch wie würde ein dritter weltkrieg
Aussehen und wodurch könnte ausgelöst werden ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp gewünscht und bekommt jetzt alle wichtigen facts zu diesem hochbrisanten
thema herzlich willkommen bei pixum science fiction
Wenn man denkt dass der hochexplosive konflikt in und um syrien lediglich
Regional ist täuscht man sich gewaltig immer wieder würde in diesem kontext in diesem zusammenhang auch darüber spekuliert ob die lage dort früher oder später
zu einem möglichen dritten weltkrieg eskalieren kann erst jetzt hat sich ein russischer
armeegeneral dazu geäußert demnach sei die lage noch nicht reif für einen dritten weltkrieg
Da die politiker noch genug verstand besitzen würden dieses zu verhindern denn das sind nur männer die für die großen verantwortlich nationen
Stehen da muss es sich um einen wahren optimisten handeln gerade noch hat donald trump mit einem raketenangriff gedroht
wahnsinn denn viele verschiedene parteien mit unterschiedlichen interessen sind involviert und das macht es nicht harmloser das horrorszenario
eine russische angriff auf amerikanische einsatzkommandos oder eben umgekehrt diese drohung steht
Im raum egal ob aus versehen oder mit voller absicht wenn das passiert dann ist die große frage wie die usa oder eben russland
reagieren die daraus resultierende eskalation könnte weit über syrien hinausgehen an sehr vielen
staatsspitzen stehen nicht ruhige besonnene politiker sondern eben gerade das gegenteil und jeweils steht in einem
Solchen konflikt ihre macht auf dem spiel eine sehr gefährliche situation viele
experten experten sehen tatsächlich vor allem russland als möglichen auslöser
für eine weltweite eskalation demnach könnte der syrien-konflikt das ende vom anfang sein und in einem wesentlich größeren
ausmaß enden nämlich in einem krieg zwischen russland und der nato schon jetzt
sprechen manche experten der experten bezüglich des verhältnisses des westens
zu russland von einem
Zweiten kalten krieg und über den krieg der zukunft nachzudenken und zu schreiben genau das ist der job
Des us strategen of cool seiner meinung nach würde ein dritter weltkrieg beginnen ohne
Dass wir es bemerken würden denn der auslöser für die weltweite
eskalation sei nicht unbedingt die zerstörung einer stadt oder ein militärischer angriff auf eine bestimmte region
Kohl, ist überzeugt davon ein dritter weltkrieg ist kein zweiter
Weltkrieg nur mit modernen waffen kohl zufolge ist dagegen eine attacke
Im weltraum viel wahrscheinlicher als ein möglicher kriegs auslöser ein satellit der die kommunikation und navigation einer region
sicherstellt hätte dann plötzlich und dann plötzlich ausfällt und mit dem gps mobilfunk und internet an land plötzlich genauso angreifbar
und verletzlich wie sein militär und die einwohner genauso denkbar seien erste attacken
Im cyberspace also hacker angriffe auf wichtige ziele wie etwa das militär börsen oder sonstige wichtige
einrichtungen die das zusammenleben und die sicherheit eines landes
gewährleisten sollen fest steht jedenfalls die treibenden kräfte eines möglichen dritten weltkriegs sind die atommächte
Und dann bleibt da nur zu hoffen dass sie sich bewusst sind darüber welche wahnsinnigen konsequenzen
deren einsatz hätte dennoch die atomwaffen werden als
Letztes mittel werden sie alle im hinterkopf haben und donald m
Hat ja auch schon darüber gesprochen ja und vor allem wenn großstädte krankenhäusern zivilisten
Angegriffen werden vielleicht würde dies aber auch bewusst vermieden werden und hauptkampf gebiete auf weiter entfernte regionen eingegrenzt werden die berühmten
stellvertreterkriege in einem dritten weltkrieg könnten zudem
internationale gremien dazu dienen diplomatisch vorzugehen und als
kommunikationskanal zwischen den gegnern zu agieren manche experten
experten gehen davon aus dass ein möglicher dritter weltkrieg sogar über einige jahrzehnte dauern könnte
Der grund dafür die ressourcen werden nicht sehr schnell erschöpft sein anders als im totalen krieg werden
Wohl nicht alle jungen männer der beteiligten länder mobilisiert und es werden wohl auch nicht alle zur verfügung stehenden waffen
Eingesetzt so könnten die menschen eventuell lernen mit dem krieg zu leben eine furchtbare vision anfang
Des jahres hat ein us mathematiker eine große datenmenge analysiert und einen möglichen zeitpunkt für den ausbruch
Des dritten weltkriegs errechnet demnach ist die wahrscheinlichkeit für einen globalen bewaffneten konflikt hoch der studie zufolge
wird noch bis zum jahr 2100 50 ein großer
zwischenstaatlicher konflikt ausbrechen da ist bei all den ganzen ja spannenden vermutung muss man sagen aber auch keine
forschungsgruppe dieser welt kann in die glaskugel sehen
Und wie ein krieg am ende beginnt und verläuft ist sicher von vielen verschiedenen faktoren abhängig aber eines scheint sich immer mehr heraus zu kristallisieren
Wenn wir noch in den 80er und 90er jahren geglaubt haben dass die welt immer vernünftiger wird und deshalb
einige jahrhunderte dauernde friedensperiode naht sind diese friedenspartner 7 inzwischen verflogen an das war ja damals
Die die großen friedens und die großen abrüstungsverträge zwischen den großen mächten
Nato und udssr wenn er es neues aus dem bereich politik wissenschaft und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp
Dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich garantiert und zu beginn gibt es noch ein kleines kunden als dankeschön
Wenn er euch dort anmeldet einfach draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
Genauso locker vergesst nie geht es weiter mit dafür auch drauf klicken so wäre ein atomkrieg ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran